what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and sony seems to be
switching things up yet again with their
spider-verse now sony has been kind of
all over the place recently they had
some success with venom and venom let
there be carnage and spider-man no way
home was one of the greatest movies of
all time both in the fans eyes and at
the box office and it pretty much came
out still during a pandemic but then
they go and they make something like
morbius now morbius has mixed reviews
but overall it wasn't a total and
complete trainwreck although most of the
fanbase did not really like the movie
sony teased spider-man being in the film
and didn't never really happen except
for in that post-credits scene where
michael keaton's vulture briefly
mentioned spider-man but despite how
morbius performed and whether you liked
it or not the post-credits scene set up
some kind of hope despite it being kind
of confusing but it gave us hope that
sony kind of had a plan for spider-man
and the rest of this sony universe that
they're building and although sony might
actually have a plan with their
spider-man universe i am worried about
it because it seems to be changing
constantly and today we even have a new
report from an actress that is from the
craven the hunter movie talking about
how craven the hunter is going to be a
different marvel movie from sony is this
bad is this good we'll talk about it in
this video and talk about what sony has
up and coming so if you love spiderman
and you're interested to see where this
universe goes be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos now i will say i am worried about
what direction sony is going to go but
at the same time this universe does have
a lot of potential and craven the hunter
has the potential to be a pretty good
movie and let's go ahead and start off
by talking about this recent report that
tells us that craven the hunter is
already starting to go in a different
direction than a normal sony marvel film
recently deadline sat down with actress
ariana dubose who was recently cast as
the villain calypso in craven the hunter
and in this interview with deadline she
talks about how this movie differs from
the past sony marvel movies they
actually just say marvel movies not
specifically sony marvel movies so we
can kind of just throw all marvel movies
in there however of course we're mainly
concerned with the spiderverse but this
is what she had to say about the movie
in the interview in the interview
deadline asked her how is the craven the
hunter movie going she said it's cool
it's going well i mean for as much as i
believe i'm allowed to say about it i
think it's going swimmingly which then
deadline asked it's exciting that marvel
seems to be really pushing for change
now before i talk about what she said in
response to this i do find it rather odd
that they're talking about marvel
generally here when most fans know that
sony marvel and the marvel cinematic
universe are completely different two
completely separate things marvel
doesn't have that much pull with the
sony movies although they do consult
with kevin feige but that does not mean
they listen to him so we know that there
are sony marvel movies and regular mcu
marvel movies but in response to
deadlines saying that marvel seems to be
really pushing for change debose said
yeah i'm proud of them i think all of
these franchise pieces it's all about
your growth and it's exciting to be a
part of something that feels like it's
taking a step in a different direction i
feel like they're just allowing this to
live in whatever world it needs to live
in which is kind of cool i don't like
work experiences i'm asked to fit a box
because my job is to discover the box
and to define the box that's my job in
my opinion i mean it is 2022. so she
already says in this interview that this
movie feels like it's taking a step in a
different direction than the normal i'm
gonna say sony marvel movies and the
sony marvel movies are already in a
different direction than the regular
marvel movies so it's all just kind of
getting different now and it makes you
wonder how exactly is this going to be
different and is that going to be good
or bad here's the thing sony actually
does have the ability to make a good
marvel movie however right now it just
seems like they kind of lack direction
for their own universe they don't quite
understand what they want it to be yet
they have spider-man who is a massive
success but they share tom holland
spider-man with disney and marvel
studios and although we don't know the
actual contract between disney and sony
most of us believe that sony can't
really use tom holland's spider-man in
their own spider-man universe tom hall
and spider-man is strictly meant for the
mcu this is why originally when the
morbius trailer came out we saw a
picture of spider-man on the wall but it
wasn't tom holland's spider-man and this
is where we can talk about kind of the
lack of direction here it seemed like
sony did have plans to introduce a
spider-man in morbius they teased us
with that photo but then they took it
out that was not in the movie at all and
this came right after the success of
spider-man no way home where they
brought back andrew garfield and toby
mcguire and after a few weeks of the
movie being out and having massive
success all of the insiders started to
come out and report that sony is
thinking about bringing toby maguire
back for other projects and andrew
garfield back for other projects as well
now this is exciting but it also kind of
complicates things even further because
now it looks like there are indeed going
to be two separate spider-mans whether
that's andrew garfield and sony and tom
holland in the marvel cinematic universe
or toby maguire at sony or both of them
it seems like there's going to be a
clear distinction between the mcu
spider-man and sony spider-man and the
key point for this is the post-credit
scene for venom let there be carnage and
then the post-credits scene for
spider-man no way home the post-credit
scene for venom let there be carnage
teased us with a tom hardy venom
crossover with tom holland spider-man
finally a venom vs spider-man film and
people love tom hardy as venom and
people love tom holland as spider-man so
this was really really exciting however
they kind of played us here because in
the post-credits of spider-man no way
home they instantly took back tom
hardy's venom to the sony universe
however they left a part of the venom
symbiote in the mcu showing us that yes
there is going to be a venom in the mcu
but it is not going to be tom hardy's
however at the same time tom hardy has
expressed that venom 3 is going to be if
he has any say in it a venom versus
spider-man film therefore there is going
to be another spider-man so again it
looks like sony might have changed their
mind as something new came up maybe
there was going to be a tom hardy venom
and tom holland spider-man crossover but
then andrew garfield and toby maguire
came on board for spider-man now way
home and they took that as an
opportunity to maybe have their own
spider-man now here's the deal this is
actually fine this can be pulled off in
a very very good way if spider-man no
way home showed us anything it's that
the spider-man can interact with each
other and the multiverse is real and
that includes the sony universe that's a
part of the multiverse so sony can
actually have their own spider-man and
bring andrew garfield back and toby
maguire back and have them in the same
movie again or separate movies it
doesn't actually matter the only thing
that actually matters is the direction
that they want to take everything and
how connected they want to make the
whole universe because the morbius
post-credits scene mentioned spider-man
then they took it out but then when it
released again they put it back in this
once again shows us that sony is kind of
on the fence about what they want to do
and then they announce a movie about el
muerto such a small character and they
cast bad bunny to play him this is an
odd choice and then we hear that the
crave in the hunter movie is going to be
very different than anything we've seen
before from marvel and this is very
scary and it's concerning but i think
sony does have the ability if they get
really focused and get a really good
idea on what they want this universe to
be to actually make a really good
universe that can cross over with tom
holland spider-man and the three
spider-man can be in the same film again
hopefully craven the hunter is different
in a very good way hopefully sony has
realized that they need to take a
different direction with these one-off
movies they're doing and also get some
continuity in their universe because we
haven't heard really anything about
spider-man being in the craven hunter
movie but madame webb is also coming up
in 2023 and that has huge multiversal
connections where again they could bring
back andrew garfield toby maguire and
tom holland in the same movie they could
even introduce new spider-man in the
film like miles morales or spider-man
2099 there's also a spider-woman movie
that is coming up not too long from now
and this has a lot of potential as well
so everything is there they have the
potential to make a really good universe
and make really good movies inside of
this universe and there's potential for
huge crossovers here it's just a matter
of if sony can nail it or not and i
truly hope they do but let me know what
you think about all of this in the
comments down below do you think sony's
going in the right direction or do you
think they need a reboot with the
universe entirely let me know your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any future marvel videos for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof